It may look like we're taking a relaxing summer stroll,...
...but actually, we're getting down to business.
I'm here with Wall Street Journal reporter Rachel Bachman...
...to discuss the benefits of the walking work meeting.
Rachel, we've known for a while that people have enjoyed taking it outside.
But now there's new research showing that there are more benefits...
...than we previously understood.
Yes, that's right.
Some people feel like they actually have better ideas and more ideas...
...when they're walking than when they're sitting down.
And the research actually backs this up.
Sounds like a great idea.
So let's get down to the basics,..
...the tips of taking a walk.
What is the optimal number of people for a walking work meeting?
Well Tanya, we are in it.
Two is best.
As you can see, sometimes in a narrow walkway,...
...it's tough to get more than two spaces side-by-side.
So you can't bring the whole conference room, then...
...that's not gonna happen?
No, leave the PowerPoint at home.
Two is optimal,...
...but you know, a lot of meetings are two people.
Right, that's true.
And other folks I talked to said they liked the phenomenon of being side-by-side.
They like how it feels more equal.
You're not sitting across a big desk.
That kind of erases the hierarchies between coworkers.